por fin después de más de mil peticiones
que nos habéis enviado hoy vamos a
hablar de méxico méxico es un país que
puede presumir de tener el presidente
más guapo del planeta para los que veáis
este vídeo desde españa os diré que
enrique peña nieto es algo así como
pedro sánchez pero capaz de ganar unas
elecciones es más estos dos políticos
tienen muchísimas cosas en común ambos
vienen de un partido de centroizquierda
ahogado por los casos de corrupción los
dos tienen unos índices de popularidad
catastróficos y los dos intentan
mejorarlos a partir de estrategias
políticas tan descacharrantes que darían
para un número de élite
en el caso de enrique peña nieto- su
última maniobra política audaz ha sido
reunirse nada menos que con donald trump
es la primera vez en décadas en la que
un presidente mexicano invita a un
candidato a la casa blanca que está en
plena campaña electoral y encima el
candidato es nada menos que donald trump
un señor cuyo programa político se basa
en insultar sistemáticamente a los
mexicanos cinco días después de esta
reunión el candidato republicano subía
dos puntos en la intención de votos
y os preguntaréis interés puede tener
peña nieto- en ayudarle a donald trump
en su carrera a la casa blanca lo cierto
es que este 2016 no ha sido nada fácil
para este hombre en septiembre ha
presentado su informe anual de gobierno
cuando es el presidente de mexico más
impopular desde 1944 así que presentarse
como el justiciero que consiguió que
donald trump pidiera perdón a todos los
mexicanos sonaba muy bien
por desgracia el plan no le ha salido
como pensaba pero la pregunta es qué ha
hecho peña nieto- para caer en están mal
a los mexicanos porque los anteriores
presidentes de méxico tampoco que lo
hayan hecho mucho mejor y es más peña
nieto- empezó en el gobierno con
bastantes buenas intenciones en sólo
cuatro años ha sido capaz de aprobar más
de 13 reformas políticas muy importantes
y tal vez ésta sea una de las razones
por las cuales ha caído tan rápido en
los índices de popularidad vamos a ver
las dos más importantes
y la reforma de la justicia no es ningún
secreto que en méxico tiene un problema
grave de violencia y narcotráfico en los
últimos tres años han muerto más civiles
en la guerra de sudán con sudán del sur
y no es casualidad que el sistema
judicial mexicano sea uno de los más
arcaicos del mundo está inspirado nada
menos que en la inquisición
a diferencia del resto de países
democráticos en mexico no existen los
juicios orales es decir al juez se le
entrega un informe escrito con toda la
información que necesita para comprender
el caso y a partir de ahí dicta betis
aun como existe la presunción de
inocencia y por eso cualquier juez puede
investigar té e incluso meterte a
prisión de forma preventiva por supuesto
que a los imputados no se les permite ni
presentar pruebas ni defenderse lo único
que pueden hacer es responder a las
preguntas impositivas que les hace el
juez y por supuesto eso que vemos en las
películas de 500 mil software
presidencia tampoco existe en méxico es
más si decides guardar silencio se usa
en tu contra por otra parte como no hay
juicios orales y todo se tiene que
presentar por escrito los casos se
convierten en montañas de informes
cuadernos carpetas llenas de papeles
papeles que se tiene que leer el juez
para poder dictar sentencia así que
imaginaros lo que pueden retrasarse los
casos y por supuesto todo esto regado
con la salsa picante de la brutalidad
policial y la corrupción el resultado
alrededor de tres cuartas partes de los
homicidios se quedan sin resolver y el
público se ha acostumbrado al
espectáculo de soldados enmascarados que
desfilan ante las cámaras a
narcotraficantes o sicarios
recientemente detenidos para verlos
libres días después no sólo eso
de la mitad de los presos mexicanos no
han sido condenados y están ahí por
prisión preventiva pero es que además
según varios estudios la mayoría de los
veredictos están equivocados para que os
hagáis una idea el 5% de los convictos
confesó su crimen porque amenazaron a su
familia es decir que en mexico meten en
la cárcel a los inocentes y dejan libres
a los culpables eso explica por qué el
90% de los ciudadanos no denuncia nunca
los delitos por eso en el año 2008 el
anterior presidente felipe calderón
aprobó la mayor reforma judicial de la
historia de mexico básicamente cambió
todo este sistema al que llaman
literalmente inquisitivo y puso en su
lugar un sistema penal garantista como
el que tenemos en el resto de países
occidentales
el problema que no puedes cambiar todo
el sistema jurídico de un país de la
noche a la mañana por eso el trabajo de
implementación le ha tocado a enrique
peña nieto- y hablamos de un proceso que
puede durar más de 10 años solo pensar
en todos los jueces y abogados de mexico
que prácticamente tienen que volver a
estudiar su carrera por no hablar de
todos los edificios que hay que
construir para albergar los espacios
para hacer los juicios los tribunales
etcétera y por supuesto hay que esperar
a cerrar todos los casos que se
empezaron a tramitar con el plan antiguo
mientras tanto el crimen en méxico sigue
en escalada año tras año y peña nieto-
lo haga bien o lo haga mal nunca llegará
a ver los frutos de esta reforma pero
sin duda alguna la medida más
controvertida ha sido ésta
del sistema educativo el sistema
educativo de méxico es el peor de toda
la ocde y el 60% de los niños mexicanos
ni siquiera va a escuelas sino que les
mandan a guarderías la cuarta parte de
los centros educativos está que se cae a
cachos no tiene ni laboratorios ni
bibliotecas y no es porque méxico se
gaste poco dinero en educación
y dedica más presupuesto a la educación
que español suizo pero el 93% se va a
pagar salarios para que os hagáis una
idea el gobierno mexicano ni siquiera
tiene un censo con el número de escuelas
que hay en mexico y todo el control del
sistema educativo está en manos de los
sindicatos de maestros que son quienes
fijan los sueldos y quienes dicen a que
gen tiene que contratar por eso la
reforma de peña nieto- incluye dos
puntos muy controvertidos el primero
consiste en hacer que los salarios de
los maestros sean públicos transparentes
y proporcionales al resto de salarios de
la función pública el segundo consiste
en la implementación de un examen a
nivel nacional que tendrían que pasar
todos los niños de méxico sin importar
en qué escuela han estudiado para los
que nos veis desde españa algo así como
una selectivos
pero ese examen no solamente es para los
alumnos sino también para los maestros
es decir que por primera vez se evalúa a
los profesores tanto para que entren a
trabajar como para que se mantengan en
su puesto o asciendan como os podéis
imaginar esto ha puesto a los maestros
en pie de guerra pero a un nivel que ya
no el año pasado se organizó una huelga
en el sur de méxico que dejó sin clase a
más de un millón de alumnos
las imágenes que estáis viendo ahora son
de los profesores que no apoyaron la
huelga a los que sus compañeros de
sindicato le raparon la cabeza pero
esperad un momento porque esto no es
nada comparado con las protestas de este
año al menos seis muertos sin más de 100
heridos es el saldo provisional del
enfrentamiento entre maestros mexicanos
y fuerzas de seguridad en el sureño
estado de oaxaca en la lucha contra la
reforma educativa es decir que la
apuesta de peña nieto es muy arriesgada
y hay que reconocerle valor por haberse
atrevido a sacar estas reformas tan
difíciles como necesarias ahora bien
también tenemos que reconocer que
es su praxis política no ha estado a la
altura de las circunstancias ni siquiera
fue capaz de evitar la fuga del chapo en
2015 recordad que se trataba del
narcotraficante más peligroso del mundo
que consiguió escaparse de la cárcel
haciendo un túnel en el que solo faltaba
aire acondicionado
hay escándalos de corrupción que afectan
directamente a su persona hace año y
medio se descubrió que el grupo oiga que
es una constructora mexicana regaló a la
mujer de peña nieto- una mansión por
valor de 7 millones de dólares poco
después el gobierno de mexico contrataba
al grupo hija para que construyera una
línea ferroviaria entre mexico df y
querétaro tras una investigación
peñanieto salía culpable pero en lugar
de dimitir cerró el caso en estas
palabras les pido perdón sin embargo
poco después de esto la periodista que
había destapado el escándalo carmen
aristegui fue despedida del medio para
el que trabajaba pero los escándalos no
terminan aquí a principios de este mes
de septiembre la universidad en la que
peña nieto- estudió la carrera confesó
que el presidente había plagiado su
tesis para la licenciatura por supuesto
que él lo niega y aquí nadie límite ni a
nadie le quitan el ticket es más su
brillante estrategia para mejorar su
imagen a parte de reunirse con donald
trump ha consistido en el lanzamiento de
esta campaña publicitaria de tan mal
gusto
y que supongo que los mexicanos estaréis
hartos de ver una y otra vez lo bueno
casi no se cuenta pero cuenta mucho y la
pregunta es todavía le queda algo de
capital político a peña nieto para poder
aprobar alguna reforma seria podeis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios en visual político vamos a
seguir muy de cerca lo que ocurre en
méxico con peña nieto así que si os
interesa este tema no olvidéis en
suscribiros para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones como siempre si
alguien quiere profundizar más
encontrarán varios links en la
descripción si os ha gustado este vídeo
tarde a like y nos vemos en el próximo
una baza y hasta pronto